these women look like they could kiss my
ass like they're invincible and they
know it I want to know what that feels
like
Spanx are something ladies wear to like
squeeze your fat in I don't know where
that fat goes truthfully I think Spanx
are kind of dumb but I'm willing to
cheat to look sexy your compute where
does the penis go
these are Spanx I'm gonna try them on
it's like a long underwear very very
masculine very very strong straps
it feels like a French person is hugging
you oh yeah
like in an intense way got you I got you
bring it last where does it go where
does it go well it can't go any was
distributed strip yes I assume that
there's just a lot of holes inside of us
and when we wear this those holes get
filled
I think it did smooth out my curbs but
it didn't like make my curves concave
all in all I was let down
now that the shirts tighter it's it's
clearer that I may not be the fittest
man I feel like a mime like I can only
communicate with my body I've wear this
out under my clothes this is humiliating
to be wearing I feel like I'm showing a
lot of nipple right now pull these up a
little bit here I thought they were
gonna be no big deal but they're
actually kind of like I like the
sleekness I feel really I feel like a
anything I do would be bastards endings
in bouncing I'm ready to fight are you
yeah time to get dangerous
sure one more try one more try this and
see that's very unsafe ah so sweaty